interesting about me being here today i  was thinking about this on the way up is  the last time  because you guys just publicly announced  your breakup yeah the last time i was  here was when history hyenas had just  broken up  oh yeah wow  right yeah it's a breakup thing  and it's interesting because  i know it's interesting yeah because i  just was like oh wow like how like  poetic  now  because remember when i came in remember  when i came in remember yeah what what  what did you put on  team y'all janice  oh whoa  yeah  [Laughter]  yo it's the same shirt  it's the signature  you would be team kalyla no no no no no  yeah in real life you're my team right  100 yeah